les mannequins étaient à l'honneur ce
week end à maurepas la fashion tour
grand casting national de mode avait
déroulé son tapis rouge dans un centre
commercial mort d'asia
c'était l'occasion pour des apprentis
mannequins de défiler devant un jury
d'experts une première expérience qui se
veut avant tout formatrice achetant
vraiment que ses problèmes quand on voit
derrière au niveau du maquillage de la
coiffure on a des bons conseils sur les
tenues aussi donc on sent vraiment que
l'expérience derrière la compétition
était ouverte aux hommes et aux femmes à
partir de 16 ans il fallait s'inscrire
en ligne
les jeunes modèles sont avant tout les
passionnés ils voient dans ce fashion
tout un tremplin pour débuter une
carrière professionnelle
là tout ce que je veux c'est aller à
paris dans un premier temps et trouver
une agence super ici aujourd'hui je fais
toute la france il faut mais j'irai en
finale je il ya pas mal de gens qui ont
des a priori qui ont des petites
craintes on est là pour déjà les
déstresser ici c'est positif on n'est
pas là pour casser les gens c'est
vraiment une première expérience il ya
des photographes professionnels ya des
coachs professionnels pour qu'on leur
donne des conseils
c'est une façon de se familiariser avec
l'univers de la mode la compétition
s'est étalée sur trois jours vincent
mcdoom a rejoint le jury lors de la demi
finale qui a vu quatre modèles remporter
leur place pour la finale
après il ya des débouchés il ya des
bouts de photos il ya des contrats avec
des marques
pour être égérie voilà donc c'est une
première expérience pour certains c'est
déjà une pas vers la
professionnalisation pour d'autres on
retrouvera donc d'orient et chloé en
novembre prochain à paris et peut-être
même plus tard sur les plus grands
podiums internationaux
merci beaucoup